Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I read a few days ago that the man who ordered the building of the almost infinite wall of China was that first emperor, Xi Huangdi, who also decreed the burning of all the books that had been written before his time. That these two vast undertakings, the five or six hundred leagues of stone against the barbarians, and the rigorous abolition of history, that is, of the past, were the work of the same person, and were in a sense his attributes, inexplicably satisfied and at the same time disturbed me so that was jorge luis borges the wall in the books la moraia y los libros an essay published in 1950 tom ni hao
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。几天前我读到，下令修建那道近乎无限长的中国长城的人，正是那位始皇帝——秦始皇，他还下令焚毁了在他之前写下的所有书籍。这两项宏大的工程——那五六百里抵御蛮族的石墙，以及对历史（即过去）的严酷废除——竟然出自同一人之手，且在某种意义上成为了他的特征，这让我既感到莫名地满足，又感到不安。这就是豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯在1950年发表的散文《长城与书》（La muralla y los libros）中的内容。汤姆，你好。
what do you have to say to that? I completely agree, I think. I can't believe you ambushed me with that. What a rotten thing to do. It was terrible. And what was worse was that we were faffing around before recording this. I know. For exactly one hour and six minutes.
你对此有什么想说的吗？我想我完全同意。真不敢相信你竟然用这个来伏击我。这事做得太卑鄙了。太糟糕了。更糟糕的是，我们在录音前还在闲聊。我知道。整整聊了一个小时零六分钟。
And in all that time, I never thought to mention that I had some Chinese up my sleeve to ambush you with. Even when I was practicing my Chinese accent. No, I just said nothing. Yeah, that's terrible behaviour. I smiled weakly.
在那段时间里，我竟然没想过提一句我藏着关于中国的内容要来伏击你。甚至当我练习中文口音的时候，我什么都没说。是的，那真是太糟糕的行为。我尴尬地笑了笑。
But what did you say? You can't leave us all hanging, for those of us who don't. I said, hello, Tom, and welcome to the rest of history. Oh, thanks. And to everyone else. Yeah. Huang Lili Dao, Sheng Xia, to Joshi Lushi, to everybody else as well. So, Tom, Borghese, that essay published in 1950, he's talking about the first emperor of China
但你说了什么？你不能让我们大家都悬着心，对于那些不懂中文的人来说。我说：“你好，汤姆，欢迎来到《历史的余味》。”哦，谢谢。也欢迎大家。是的。还有“黄莉莉道，盛夏，到 Joshi Lushi”，也欢迎其他人。那么，汤姆，博尔赫斯那篇1950年发表的文章，他谈论的是中国的始皇帝。
and he says he built the Great Wall, but he also abolished history by destroying all the books. And very attentive listeners may remember that back in the mists of time when we record an episode about the Aztecs, the Mexica, that's what they did as well. They destroyed the books of their enemies, the histories of their enemies. But the emperor of China does it about China's own stuff yeah he does and uh the story is is that not only does he burn the books but he actually buries alive a whole array of scholars and that sense of the first emperor of china xi huangdi as a kind of menacing tyrant but i think you get the sense from that reading
他说他修建了长城，但也通过销毁所有书籍废除了历史。非常细心的听众可能还记得，在很久以前我们录制关于阿兹特克人（墨西加人）的那期节目时，他们也是这么做的。他们摧毁了敌人的书籍，摧毁了敌人的历史。但中国的皇帝是对中国自己的东西这么做。是的，他确实这么做了。而且故事是说，他不仅焚书，实际上还活埋了一大批学者。那种将中国始皇帝秦始皇视为一种威胁性暴君的感觉，但我认为从那段阅读中你能感觉到。
from bulgess who loves this kind of stuff that that it shades into the mythic, doesn't it? Borges loves figures who are playing tricks with time or constructing massive walls, all that kind of stuff. Labyrinths. Yeah, all that. And there is the sense, I think, that Shi Huangdi is, I mean, he's building walls, he's burning scholars and books, and he kind of goes mad towards the end of his life, trying to discover a cure for immortality,
从热爱这类东西的博尔赫斯那里，你会感觉到这带有一种神话色彩，不是吗？博尔赫斯喜欢那些玩弄时间或建造巨大墙壁的人物，诸如此类。迷宫。是的，所有这些。而且我认为有一种感觉，秦始皇，我的意思是，他在修墙，在焚烧学者和书籍，他在生命末期变得有些疯狂，试图寻找长生不老药。
which again is like something from a Borghese story. Yeah, the elixir of life. I mean, this is an unbelievable story. Yeah. So he is a really, really fascinating figure. And I would say most people probably in the West are not familiar with ancient Chinese history. Yeah. I mean, much less so than with Roman or Egyptian or even Assyrian history.
这又像是博尔赫斯故事里的情节。是的，长生不老药。我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的故事。是的。所以他确实是一个非常、非常迷人的人物。我想大多数西方人可能对中国古代史并不熟悉。是的。我的意思是，远不如对罗马、埃及甚至亚述历史那么熟悉。
But probably there are kind of visual markers for the reign of the first Chinese emperor, because in 1974, which is obviously a couple of decades or so after Borges wrote that story, an incredible discovery was made in a village outside Tianan in central china where the first emperor had his capital and this of course was the terracotta soldiers of the buried army which was part of the first emperor's tomb yeah and probably most people listening will have a sense of what they look like i mean it's probably the would you say the most celebrated archaeological discovery since tutankhamen i guess yeah I think so. I think if you said to people, pre-modern China, you know, ancient medieval China, do
但可能对于这位中国始皇帝的统治，人们有一些视觉上的标志，因为在1974年——显然是在博尔赫斯写那个故事几十年后——在中国中部秦始皇定都的西安郊外的一个村庄里，有一个惊人的发现，这当然就是作为始皇帝陵墓一部分的兵马俑。是的，可能大多数听众对它们的样子都有所了解。我的意思是，这大概是你会说自图坦卡蒙以来最著名的考古发现吗？我想是的。我想如果你问人们，前现代中国，你知道，古代中世纪中国，你了解什么吗？他们会说，嗯，是兵马俑吗？是长城吗？是的。我的意思是，博尔赫斯谈到了墙，但他没有谈到军队。军队在大英博物馆展出过，不是吗？十五年前，我去看了。我想有三尊。
you know anything about it? They would say, hmm, is that the Terracotta Army? Is it the Great Wall? Yeah. I mean, Borges talks about the wall, but he doesn't talk about the army. The army was at the British Museum, wasn't it? Fifteen years ago, and I went to see it. I think three.
确实有三尊人像，是的。有一种奇怪而令人难忘的感觉，因为有一种说法是，这是第一种大规模生产的产物，因为它们看起来是完全相同的。但我们会谈到这一点，因为我们会谈到他的遗产。但我们需要谈谈这个人物本身，不是吗？还有他在中国历史上的地位，这显然是巨大的。对，因为我认为他是一个人物。他的故事，他所扮演的角色，与我们更熟悉的皇帝、法老和国王的角色有回响。所以无论是。
There were three of the figures, yeah. There is something weird and haunting, because there's an argument that it's the first kind of mass-produced, because they're kind of these identical-looking figures. But we'll come to this, because we'll come to his legacy. But we need to talk about the character himself, don't we? And also his place in Chinese history, which is obviously colossal. Right, because I think that he is a figure. His story, the role that he plays, has echoes of the role played by emperors and pharaohs and kings that are more familiar to us. So whether
埃及或罗马的历史等等，但他显然也是中国历史中一个非常、非常有代表性的人物。我认为特别是中国历史中存在的那些矛盾心理。一方面，他一直被中国人视为坏皇帝、暴君、极权主义人物的典型。正如我们将看到的，他体现了极权主义的趋势。但另一方面，也有人认为他是第一位皇帝，他是第一个建立中国帝国国家的人。他通过将之前破碎的王国从混乱中拯救出来做到了这一点。你有七个王国在相互争斗。这非常像《权力的游戏》。
the history of Egypt or Rome or whatever, but he's obviously also a very, very representative figure of Chinese history. And I think particularly of the ambivalences that you get in Chinese history. So on the one hand, he has always served the Chinese as the archetype of a bad emperor, of a tyrant, of a totalitarian figure. He embodies totalitarian trends, as we will see. But on the other hand, there is also a sense that he is the first emperor, he is the first person who constitutes the imperial state of China. And he does this by redeeming what had previously been fractured kingdoms from chaos. You have seven kingdoms who are fighting among themselves. It's very kind of Westeros,
非常像《权力的游戏》。通过将它们锻造成一个单一的帝国秩序，他建立了一个一直持续到20世纪的模板。所以甚至比奥古斯都还要成功，汤姆，他是一个明显的比较对象。这种连续性实际上不仅延续到中国帝制的终结，而且一直延续到今天。因为在某种意义上，在当代中国，尽管它是共产主义国家，但始皇帝被视为一种英雄。所以有一部令人难以置信的电影。我知道你没看过，因为我们之前谈过。它是我绝对最喜欢的电影之一，叫《英雄》。它美得令人窒息。它设定在七国战争时期。它的核心是刺客试图杀死秦王，而秦王将继续。
very Game of Thrones. And by forging them into a single imperial order, he is establishing a template that will endure right the way up into the 20th century. So more successful even than Augustus, Tom, who would be an obvious comparator. continuities that actually run not just up to the end of the Chinese empire, but right the way up into the present day. Because there is a sense in which in contemporary China, communist though it is, the first emperor is seen as a kind of a hero. So there's an incredible film. I know you haven't seen it because we were talking about it earlier. It's one of my absolute favorite films called Hero. It's stunningly beautiful. And it's set in this period of the wars between the seven kingdoms. And it has at its heart an attempt by assassins to kill the King of Qin who will go on
成为第一位皇帝。你站在刺客一边，但反转在于，最终你反而支持秦王，因为他将继续创造现代中国。因此没有他，就不会有中国。这种始皇帝作为某人的感觉，奇怪的是，在1973年，这是在毛主席生命末期，毛泽东主席的生命末期，毛派期刊《红旗》发表了一篇社论，将始皇帝焚书坑儒描述为进步措施，这太令人惊奇了。是的。为了一个更幸福的中国而采取的强硬措施。
to become the first emperor. And you're siding with the assassins, but the twist is that ultimately you end up rooting for the King of Qin because he is going to go on and create modern China. And therefore without him, there will be no China. This sense of the first emperor as someone who, weirdly, in 1973, this is towards the end of Mao's life, Chairman Mao's life, there was an editorial published in the Maoist journal, The Red Flag, which described the first emperor burning books and burying Confucian scholars alive as progressive measures, which is amazing. Yeah. Robust measures for a happier China.
正是如此。即使是现在，不仅有电影，还有四部关于始皇帝的电视剧。所以威廉·汉，你还记得我们在奥克兰时我见到的那个人吗？记得。是的。这位华裔新西兰人写了一本关于他从中国旅行到中东的精彩游记。但他谈到这一点时说，你知道，凯撒会喜欢这种关注的。是的。
Exactly. And even now, it's not only filmed, there's been four TV series about the first emperor. So William Hann, you remember who I met when we were in Auckland? I do. Yeah. Chinese New Zealander wrote a brilliant travelogue about his travels across from China to the Middle East. But he said about this, you know, Caesar would love this kind of attention. Yeah.
我想中国和罗马之间的相似之处是我对它感兴趣的原因。是的。而且共产主义的内容很迷人。我们将在节目快结束时谈到这一点，即在毛泽东时代的中国，始皇帝的声誉是如何改变的。但让我们开始吧。汤姆，我们在哪里？我们是在基督诞生前300年左右，250年左右。
And I guess the parallels between China and Rome are why I'm interested in it. Yeah. And the communist stuff is fascinating. We'll come to that towards the end of the programme, the way in which, in Mao's China, the reputation of the first emperor changed. But let's start. Tom, where are we? We are 300 years or so, 250 years before the birth of Christ.
是的。所以罗马此时是一个共和国，而中国并不存在。现在的中国是一系列交战的国家。是这样吗？是的。所以有七个战国。正如我们所说，成为第一位皇帝的人是秦王。在他的统治下，秦国征服了其他六个国家。其他六个国家认为它相当野蛮。故事说，王国的创始人是一位擅长养马的酋长，这是一种非常野蛮的行为，他被赐予了这片土地。然后秦国不断壮大，最终吞并了所有其他王国。你提到了罗马。
We are. So Rome is a republic at this point and China doesn't exist. What is now China is a series of warring states. Is that right? Yeah. So there are seven warring states. As we said, the man who becomes the first emperor is the king of Qin. Under his rule, Qin conquers the other six states. And it is seen by the other six states as pretty barbaric. The story goes that the founder of the kingdom was a chieftain who was expert in horse breeding, which is a kind of very barbarian thing to do, who gets given this tranche of land. And then Chin grows and grows and ends up swallowing all the other kingdoms. And you mentioned Rome.
我的意思是，这有点像希腊人如何看待罗马的扩张。所以罗马在这一时期正忙于与迦太基作战。但马其顿也是另一个平行点。我正要说马其顿。所以马其顿，它位于希腊世界、希腊世界的北部边缘，最终占据了主导地位。秦国也是一样，对吧？它更尚武，更粗犷。是的。
I mean, there is a slight sense there of how the Greeks, for instance, will see the expansion of Rome. So Rome at this period is busy fighting against Carthage. But also Macedon is the other parallel. I was about to say Macedon. So Macedon, which is on the northern fringe of the kind of Hellenic world, the Greek world, and then ends up dominating. Chin is the same, right? It's more warlike, it's more rugged. Yes.
其他人认为它可能有点落后，有点粗鲁。但那些尚武的美德使它获得了成功。是的。所以这很可能就是为什么一旦秦王征服了其他六个王国，我的意思是，他在宣扬他所取得的成就的规模时并不含蓄，所以他在他的铭文中吹嘘他为天下带来了和平，他使强大和叛逆的人谦卑，并为地球的四个角落带来了稳定。你知道，在某种意义上，他的王朝在他死后只持续了四年。
And the others regard it as perhaps a bit backward, a bit uncouth. But those martial virtues are what make it successful. Yes. And so this may well be why once the king of chin has conquered the other six kingdoms i mean he's he's not reticent in proclaiming the scale of what he's achieved so on his inscriptions he boasts that he brought peace to all under the heavens and that he has humbled the mighty and rebellious and brought stability to the four ends of the earth you know there's a sense in which he's actually, his dynasty only lasts another four years after his death.
但正如我们所说，在另一种意义上，他所建立的东西将持续到1911年，当时最后一位中国皇帝被废黜。是的，溥仪。我认为真正关注这种连续性的不同寻常之处是正确的，因为显然罗马帝国消失了，没有留下任何痕迹。哈里发国分裂和破碎。印度直到英国时期才成为一个连贯的整体。但在中国，即使帝国可能内爆，可能分裂。
But as we say, there is another sense in which what he has established will last until 1911, when the last Chinese emperor is deposed. Yeah, Puyi. And I think that it is really right to focus in on how unusual this sense of continuity is, because obviously the Roman Empire vanishes, there is no trace of it. The Caliphate fragments and fractures. India is never a coherent whole until the British period. But in China, even though the empire may implode, may fragment,
可能破碎，它总是会重新组合在一起。我认为你有这样一种感觉，从这一时期开始，统一的帝国被中国人视为唯一合法的统治形式。这反过来又提出了两个非常、非常有趣的问题。第一个是，始皇帝是如何做到这一点的？他是如何成功建立这样一种持久的帝国统治模式的，这种模式不仅持续了几个世纪，而且持续了数千年？但还有，博尔赫斯在你开头读的那段话所聚焦的问题，他废除了历史吗？这是零年，还是他在借鉴比他古老得多的传统？
may fracture, it always kind of comes back together again. And I think you have this sense that from this period on, a unified empire is seen by the Chinese as really the only legitimate form of rule. And so that in turn kind of raises two really, really interesting questions. And the first is, how did the first emperor do this? How did he succeed in establishing such a kind of enduring model of imperial rule, a model that would last for not just centuries but millennia? But also, that question that is focused by the passage from Borges that you read at the beginning, has he abolished history? Is it year zero, or is he drawing on traditions that are much older than him?
是的。所以博尔赫斯显然对这是一个零年、皇帝重新开始的想法很着迷。这是一个非常有诱惑力的想法。中国历史显然早于那位始皇帝。所以我认为中国年表可以追溯到这个家伙之前的几千年，对吗？是的，都在他之前。所以博尔赫斯在他的文章中指出了这一点。我的意思是，这就是为什么他觉得这如此令人不安，废除历史的想法是因为博尔赫斯认识到，对于中国人来说，在某种意义上，历史对中国传统更重要，对中国人来说比对任何。
Yeah. So Borges was obviously fascinated by this idea that it was a year zero, that the emperor was starting again. And it's one that's very seductive. Chinese history obviously predates that first emperor. So am I right in thinking the Chinese chronology, that goes back thousands of years before this guy? Yeah, it's all before him. So Borges in his essay points this out. I mean, this is why he finds it so unsettling, the idea of abolishing history is because Borges recognizes that for the Chinese, in a sense, history is more important to the Chinese tradition, is more important to the Chinese than to any
可比的文明更重要。所以他在那篇文章中写道，当秦始皇下令历史将从他开始时，中国年表已经有3000年的历史，包括黄帝、庄子、孔子、老子。他在那里引用了一位皇帝和三位圣人，他们显然都先于始皇帝。黄帝是一位传说中的文化英雄，基本上是一位神圣的人物，就像奥西里斯在法老王朝之初统治埃及一样。对。庄子和老子在战国时期都活着，在第一位皇帝结束那个时期之前。他们是道教的典范。他们遵循“道”，即道路。其目的是使天地万物和谐，必须说他们不是稳定世界帝国的明显指南。所以有一个关于庄子的著名故事，我相信很多人都听说过，他有一天睡着了，梦见自己是一只蝴蝶，然后当他醒来时，他不知道自己是一个梦见自己是蝴蝶的人，还是现在梦见自己是一个人的蝴蝶。这非常博尔赫斯。所以这不是那种能让你去征服六个国家的精神。是的，在始皇帝的一生中，是的，道教并不是他们后来成为的那种哲学流派，他们更像是印度的瑜伽士，他们更。
comparable civilization. And so he writes in that essay, Chinese chronology was already 3,000 years long and included the yellow emperor, Changsu, Confucius, Lao Tzu, when Shi Huangdi ordered that history would begin with him. What he's doing there, he's citing an emperor and three sages, all of whom obviously had preceded the first emperor. The Yellow Emperor is a kind of legendary culture hero who is basically a kind of divine figure, like Osiris ruling Egypt at the beginning of the line of the pharaohs. Right. Trang Tzu and Lao Tzu were both alive during the Warring States period before the
沉迷于呼吸技巧和格温妮丝·帕特洛式的非常朴素的饮食等等。是的，他们在Instagram上发布看起来很可怜的沙拉照片。正是如此。所以始皇帝对此非常蔑视。但话虽如此，道教徒确实认识到他们的教义，显然这种你想让天地和谐的想法，显然对政治有影响。所以老子说，道大，天大，地大，王亦大。域中有四大，而王居其一。所以有这样一种想法，你实际上需要一位国王来建立和谐。嗯，那种和谐的想法，汤姆。
first emperor ends that. They are exemplars of Taoism. They follow the Tao, the way. The aim of this is to bring heavens and the earth and everything in it into harmony and it has to be said that they are not obvious guides to a stable world empire so there's a famous story that's told of trangzu that i'm sure lots of people will have heard of that he falls asleep one day and dreams that he's a butterfly and then when he wakes up he doesn't know whether he's a man who dreamed he was a butterfly whether he was a butterfly now dreaming he was a man that's very balkesian so this is not the spirit that will enable you to go and conquer six kingdoms yeah and during the lifetime of the first emperor yeah the taoists aren't really a philosophical school to the degree that they will become they're kind of i think they're more like yogis in india they're kind of
显然是儒家思想的核心，不是吗？所以孔子生活在我们要谈论的那个家伙之前大约一个世纪左右。他的模式，他的梦想是一个平衡和稳定的世界，在这个世界里，尘世达到了与宇宙相同的和谐水平。没错。那将意味着单一的政治秩序。嗯，他真正谈论的是善良，多米尼克。哦，汤姆，那很好，因为我们在《历史的余味》中都是关于善良的，不是吗？所以当我说是善良时，我的意思是，他有这样一种想法，如果每个人都知道他们应有的位置，如果每个人都根据他们的角色表现良好。
into yeah breathing techniques and gwyneth paltrow very austere diets and things yeah they're posting pictures of like pathetic looking salads on Instagram. Exactly. So the first emperor, very contemptuous of that. But having said that, the Taoists do recognize that their teachings, obviously this idea that you want to bring the heavens and earth into harmony, obviously that has implications for politics. And so Lao Tzu says the Tao is great, heaven is great, earth is great, and the king is great. There are four greats in the state and the king is one of these. So there's this idea that you actually need one king to establish harmony. Well, that idea of harmony, Tom,
那么完美的国家就会出现。所以他用一句名言总结了这一点：君君，臣臣，父父，子子。本质上他所做的是将关系等同起来。
is obviously absolutely central to Confucianism, isn't it? So Confucius lived about a century or so earlier before the guy we're talking about. And his model, his dream is a world of balance and stability where the earthly world achieves the same level of harmony that the cosmos has. That's right. And that would imply a single political order. Well, really what he's on about is being kind, Dominic. Oh, Tom, that's nice because we're all about kindness on the rest of history, aren't we? So when I say being kind, I mean, he has this idea that if everyone knows their rightful place, if everyone behaves well, according to their roles,
父子之间的关系。必须说，他几乎不谈论女性，与统治者和臣民的关系。如果每个人都做他们应该做的事，无论是执行正确的仪式，还是，我不知道，穿正确的衣服，或者以正确的方式鞠躬，那么一切都会随之而来。当每个人都知道他或她的位置时，那么和谐将是普遍的。你知道，会有一位国王，每个人都会知道他或她的位置。那会很棒。这听起来很合理，我想。非常合理。嗯，所以我们将看看始皇帝是否同意你的观点。但这种儒家理想，即中国不仅仅是一个政治实体，它是宇宙秩序的一种表达。这是绝对贯穿中国帝国历史的东西。我认为这就是为什么，在适当的时候，中国的统一变得看起来是不可避免的。嗯，我想问你关于这一点，因为有一种感觉，不是吗，所有的中国历史都在朝着一个单一的目标前进，那就是中国的统一、力量和胜利。正是因为中国历史有这种非凡的连续性，而且中国的单位存在了这么久，我们认为这是不可避免的，总会有一个叫中国的国家，而不是一系列交战的国家。但显然没有一个叫欧洲的国家，或者至少现在还没有。或者罗马尼亚。
then the perfect state will emerge. So he sums this up in a famous phrase, let the ruler be a ruler, the subject a subject, the father a father, and the son a son. And essentially what he's doing is he's equating the relationship
正是如此。嗯，有一个叫罗马尼亚的国家，但你知道我的意思。是的。没有罗马。是的，罗马帝国并没有依然存在。是的。所以当我们看这个家伙时，我想这就是笼罩在上面的阴影，或者问题，不是吗？他是单枪匹马地对世界历史上最非凡的地缘政治成就负责吗？还是有其他因素在起作用？实际上，他的个人重要性是否比我们倾向于认为的要小？这个问题引发了笼罩在中国古代历史上的那种深刻的矛盾心理。
between the father and the son. And he barely talks about women, it has to be said, to a ruler and a subject. And if everyone does what they should, so whether that is performing the right rituals or, I don't know, wearing the right kind of clothes or bowing in the right kind, that everything will follow. And when everyone knows his or her place, then harmony will be universal. You know, there'll be one king, everyone will know his or her place. It'll all be great. That sounds very sound, I think. Very sound. Well, so we will see whether the first emperor agrees with you. But this sort of Confucian ideal that China is something more than just a political entity, that it is an expression of the order of the cosmos. This is something that absolutely runs
当然，到了早期现代，中国历史学家回顾过去，他们说这是朝着统一的不可避免的进步。他们会说在始皇帝之前2000年有10000个国家，然后战国时代有7个，然后始皇帝之后只有一个，这很好。这是一件不可避免会发生的事情。但与此同时，只有一个。这很好。这是一件不可避免会发生的事情。但与此同时，也有一种感觉，肯定是在战国时代本身。
right the way through Chinese imperial history. And I think is why, in due course, the unification of China comes to seem something inevitable. Well, I wanted to ask you about that, because there is a sense, isn't there, that all Chinese history is progressing towards a single goal, which is the unity and strength and triumph of China. And precisely because Chinese history has this extraordinary continuity and because the unit of China has existed for so long, we assume that it's inevitable, that there was always going to be a country called China and not a series of warring states. But obviously there isn't a country called Europe, or at least not yet. Or Romania.
圣人不仅在向前看，而且在特别向后看一个已经失去的统一的黄金时代。特别是，他们回顾了一个特定王朝的鼎盛时期，周朝。人们喜欢我对外语的发音。嗯，多米尼克，你是特定王朝的大师。人们喜欢我对外语的发音。嗯，多米尼克，你是舌头的大师。你是中文的大师。周朝的舌头。周。我的意思是，我绝不是中国语言学的专家。
Exactly. Well, there is a country called Romania, but you know what I mean. Yeah. There's no Roman. Yes, the Roman Empire doesn't still exist. Yeah. So when we look at this guy, I suppose that's the shadow that hangs over this, or the question, isn't it? Is he single-handedly responsible for the most extraordinary geopolitical achievements in world history? Or are there other factors at play? And actually, is his individual importance less significant than we might tend to think? That question raises kind of the deep ambivalence that hangs over the ancient history
但我很高兴涉猎。是的。好的。所以这是中国历史上统治时间最长的王朝，789年。789年。哇。太神奇了。是的。他们在大约公元前1050年推翻了前一个王朝，商朝。是的。所以这有点像，你知道，在欧洲，这是青铜时代的崩溃。这是特洛伊战争的余波。
of China. Definitely, say by the early modern period, Chinese historians are looking back and they're saying it's an inevitable progress towards unity. They'll say that 2,000 years before the first emperor there were 10,000 states, and then the age of the warring states there were seven, and then with the first emperor there's only one, and this is great. This is something that was inevitably going to happen. But at the same time, there's only one. And this is great. This is something that was inevitably going to happen. But at the same time, there is also a sense, definitely during the age of the warring states itself,
就是那个时期。周朝用参考概念来证明他们的统治是正当的，这些概念将贯穿整个历史。其中最著名的是天命的概念，即一个不能维持秩序与和谐的王朝被天所谴责，被推翻，并被一个新的王朝所取代。因此历史，一种对过去的感觉，是极其重要的，因为它使一个王朝能够证明其统治的适宜性。反过来，这意味着控制书写内容、控制传播内容、控制人们阅读内容的能力是非常、非常重要的。我的意思是，对于王朝的稳定，从而对于国家的稳定是根本性的。但周朝发生了什么，权力开始从大约公元前750年左右从王朝流失。是的。你进入了一个被中国人称为春秋时期的时期，它源于《春秋》的名字，我认为这是一个美妙的名字。在那个时期，你看到，我想这有点像中世纪欧洲神圣罗马皇帝失去对帝国整体控制的过程。但本质上。
that sages are not just looking forwards, but they're looking specifically backwards to a golden age of unity that's been lost. And specifically, they're looking back to the heyday of a particular dynasty, the Chu. And people love my pronunciation of foreign. Well, Dominic, you're the master of of a particular dynasty, the Chu. And people love my pronunciation of foreign. Well, Dominic, you're the master of tongues. You're a master of Chinese. The Zhu dynasty tongue. The Zhu. I mean, I'm not a specialist in Chinese linguistics by any means,
国王的形象，他变成了一种没有真正权威的幽灵般的人物。这就是导致分裂的过程。但汤姆，我可以问一个问题吗？在你到达战国时期之前，当这一切崩溃时，在那一点上，在周朝统治下，有没有我们所认为的统一的中国？他们统治的是一种前古典时期，比如今天的中国共和国。它小得多。它集中在中心地带。但是的，我认为有一种共同身份的感觉。正是那种共同身份让人们怀旧。他们觉得有什么东西在等待，已经存在的帝国已经破碎，应该重建。所以这就解释了始皇帝将要扮演的矛盾角色。
but I'm happy to dabble. Yeah. Okay. So this is the dynasty that rules for the longest in the whole of Chinese history, 789 years. 789 years. Wow. Amazing. Yeah. And they had overthrown the previous dynasty, the Shang, around 1050 BC. Yeah. So this is kind of, you know, in Europe, it's the Bronze Age collapse. It's the aftermath of the Trojan War.
他是一个开始新事物的人，但他也在向后看，但他想掩盖这一点。是的，但关于共同身份，非常快，共同身份不仅基于政治现实，还基于共同的语言、宗教、习俗，这些东西？不，我认为它可能更接近。
It's that kind of period. And the Jew justify their rule with reference to concepts that again will endure throughout the entire sweep of history. And the most famous of these is the idea of the mandate of heaven, that a dynasty that cannot maintain order and harmony is condemned by the heaven, overthrown, and to be replaced by a new dynasty. And therefore history, a sense of the past, is incredibly important because it's what enables a dynasty to prove its fitness to rule. And in turn, that means that an ability to control what is written, to control what is propagated, to control what people read is really, really important. I mean, fundamental to the
前罗马时代的意大利，而不是古典希腊。好的，对。所以实际上那种身份相当脆弱，你是这个意思吗？当然，是的。但我认为同样，在这些七个王国中有一种共同的感觉，即它们之间的和谐将比仅仅允许它们继续战斗和分裂要好。这确实是与孔子联系在一起的理想，他回顾过去寻求灵感，但也向前看，说，看，如果我们只是表现良好，如果儿子对父亲表现孝顺，臣民对国王表现孝顺，那么仁慈和善良的精神就会流向大地，帝国就会因此而凝聚。所以基本上，这就是孔子和追随他的儒家学者在教导这些不同王国的统治者，如果你这样做，那么和谐就会盛行。但当然，问题在于孔子说你不能通过暴力重建统一。但当然，我的意思是，那是胡说八道。这是你唯一能做到的方式就是通过暴力。是的。所以孔子，汤姆，生活在，他是，公元前550年到480年左右。所以他在始皇帝之前200年。那个时期是混乱、无政府状态、周朝继任国家之间不断的战争。正如你所说，它们被焊接在一起的唯一方法是通过武力，对吧？
stability of the dynasty and therefore to the stability of the state. But what happens under the Zhou is that power starts to drain from the dynasty from, I don't know, about 750 BC. Yeah. And you pass into a period that's called by the Chinese the Spring and Autumn Period, which derives from the name of the Spring and Autumn Annals, which I think is a kind of wonderful name. And in that period, you see, I suppose it's a bit like the process by which the Holy Roman Emperor in medieval Europe loses control over the totality of his empire. But essentially,
对。我的意思是，这是一个非常暴力、激进的世界。对。因为这七个国王中哪一个会说，是的，好吧，让我们有一个哲学家的时代。我们都退位。这根本不会发生。所以这就是将成为第一位皇帝的人介入的地方，因为正如我们将看到的，他非常不是一个儒家。他信奉一种非常不同的意识形态，一种非常不同的统治方法。我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看他做了什么。
the figure of the king, he becomes a kind of spectral figure without real authority. And this is the process which results in the fragmentation. But Tom, can I just ask a question? Before you get to the warring period, when this all falls apart, at that point, so under the Zhou Dynasty, is there what we would recognise as a unified China? Are they ruling a sort of pre-classical, say, the Republic of China today is. It's much smaller. It's concentrated kind of in the heartlands. But yeah, I think there is a sense of a common identity. And it's really that common identity that people are nostalgic for. They feel that there is something waiting, that the empire that existed has broken and it should be reconstituted. And so that explains the ambivalent role that the first emperor will come to play,
而且这一切都相当残酷。哦，我很期待。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。挥舞着长鞭，他驱赶着宇宙。他登上了权力的巅峰，统治了六个方向。
that he is someone who is starting something afresh, but he is also kind of looking backwards, but he wants to disguise that. Yeah, but just on the common identity very quickly, common identity based on not just political reality, but on shared language, religion, customs, those kinds of things? No, I think it's probably closer to
用他的棍棒鞭打世界，他的力量震撼了四海。在南方，他夺取了土地，那里的领主低下了头，脖子上挂着缰绳，恳求保命。然后他让蒙将军修建长城并保卫边境，这样蛮族就不敢再南下放牧他们的马匹，他们的人也不敢拿起武器来报复他们的仇恨。于是他抛弃了前代国王的方式，焚烧了百家的著作，以使人民无知。他收集了帝国所有的武器，并把它们带到他的首都，在那里矛和箭头被熔化了。他用熟练的将军和专家弓箭手驻守战略要点。
pre-Roman Italy than it is to classical Greece. Okay, right. So actually that identity is quite fragile, is what you're saying? For sure, yes. But I think equally, there is a sense that is shared across these seven kingdoms that a harmony between all of them would be better than just allowing them to continue to fight and to fragment. And that really is the ideal that is associated with Confucius, who is looking back for inspiration, but also looking forwards and saying, look, if we just behave well, if sons behave dutifully to their fathers and subjects behave dutifully to the king, then the spirit of benevolence and kindness will flow out across the land and the empire will just
并派遣受信任的部长和训练有素的士兵用武器守卫土地，并审问所有来往的人。那是贾谊在《过秦论》中的内容。所以这是在讨论中国的始皇帝，实际上让他听起来，汤姆，像一个非常可怕的人物。所以听起来像是一个警察国家，不是吗？每个人都被审问。每个路口都有士兵。因为旧书的销毁，人民陷入了无知。那是他死后50年写的。是的。
cohere as a result of it. And so basically, this is what Confucius and Confucian scholars who follow him are teaching the rulers of these various kingdoms, is that if you do this, then harmony will prevail. But of course, the problem with that is that Confucius is saying you can't reconstitute the unity through violence. But of course, I mean, that's a nonsense. That's the only way you can do it is through violence. Yeah. So Confucius, Tom, is living, what is he, 550 to kind of 480 or thereabouts BC. So he is 200 years before the first emperor. And that period is one of chaos, anarchy, constant war between the successor states to the Zhou dynasty. And as you say, the only way they can be welded together is through force, right?
而且贾谊是一个爱鸟者。所以他写了一篇关于猫头鹰的论文。对。猫头鹰的美丽，我认为这很棒。喜欢猫头鹰。是的。但他也是一个儒家。他在那里表现出的对皇帝的敌意，他借鉴了儒家的理想，发现始皇帝令人失望。
Right. I mean, this is a very violent, aggressive world. Right. Because which of these seven kings is going to say, yeah, all right, let's have a philosopher's age. We'll all stand down. It's just not going to happen. So this is where the man who will become the first emperor steps in, because as we will see, he is very much not a Confucian. He subscribes to a very different ideology, a very different approach to rulership. And I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we'll look and see what he did.
虽然我认为，我的意思是，我认为那里也有某种勉强的尊重，你不觉得吗？是的。我的意思是，它有效地强调了他的全能，不是吗？是的。但我认为这是儒家思想在中国历史上贯穿始终的一种主要主题的最早表达，即始皇帝通过有意识地践踏儒家理想来建立他的至高无上。而且因为历史往往是由儒家写的，我认为很难有一种不被那种批评所笼罩的对始皇帝本人的感觉。所以这又是，看着罗马的平行点。这就像参议员写关于早期凯撒的文章。敌意是根深蒂固的。对。所以这就是我们对这个家伙的感觉。现在，有趣的是，在整个播客中，我们称他为这个家伙或始皇帝，但我们并没有真正使用他的名字。这部分是因为他的名字随着时间的推移而改变，不是吗？确实如此。所以你把他比作奥古斯都，是的，奥古斯都非常喜欢改名，始皇帝也非常相似。他的出生名字似乎是政，多米尼克，正如你所知，当然意味着某种正直或适当、正确，是的，正义或。
And it's all quite brutal. Oh, I look forward to it. Come I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Cracking his long whip, he drove the universe before him. He ascended to the summit of power and ruled the six directions,
对真正语言学者的正直含义，汤姆，我想是的，正是如此。所以他是秦王和一位妃子的儿子，在他死后的几十年里，你开始得到敌对的儒家传统，说他的父亲曾是一个人质，我想当他年轻时这是完全合理的，而且当他是一个人质时，他曾与一位商人交朋友。儒家对商人怀有极大的蔑视。所以这是一件可怕的事情。他们在做生意。平庸。他们在做生意。这位商人把他的一个妃子送给了未来的秦王。
scourging the world with his rod, and his might shook the four seas. In the south he seized the land, and the lords there bowed their heads, hung halters from their necks, and pleaded for their lives. Then he caused General Meng to build the great wall and defend the borders, so that the barbarians no longer dared to come south to pasture their horses, and their men dared not take up arms to avenge their hatred. Thereupon he discarded the ways of the former kings and burned the writings of the hundred schools in order to make the people ignorant. He collected all the arms of the empire and had them brought to his capital where the spears and arrowheads were melted down. He garrisoned the strategic points with skilled generals and expert bowmen,
这个妃子将是他的母亲。虽然有更晚的，同样非常敌对的儒家传统，更进一步说，实际上秦王是这位商人和他的妃子的儿子，因此完全不合法。所以你可以看到那里有一种蓄意的尝试来抹黑他。所以他在公元前246年成为秦王。他只有13岁，所以还很年轻。他是这个非常、非常强大的国家的继承人。我们之前把它比作罗马或腓力二世和亚历山大的马其顿，征服了希腊国家。他们有一种非常、非常军国主义的思想，几乎是斯巴达水平的坚韧，技术上非常先进。所以他们开发了特别致命的弩。他们有这些庞大、训练有素的军队。任何看过《英雄》的人都会记得。
and stationed trusted ministers and well-trained soldiers to guard the land with arms, and questioned all who passed back and forth. Now that was Jia Yi in the Faults of Qin. So this is discussing the first emperor of China and actually makes him sound, Tom, like a pretty terrifying figure. So it sounds like a bit of a police state there, doesn't it? That everybody's been questioned. There are soldiers at every crossing. The people have been plunged into ignorance because of the destruction of their old books. And that was written about 50 years after his death. Yeah.
当秦军逼近时，大地颤抖的不可思议的场景。所以早在政出生于公元前255年仅四年后，秦国就已经开始了他们的征服进程。特别是，他们瞄准了周朝遗产的剩余部分。所以这个非常、非常古老、备受尊敬的王朝，在几个世纪前就已经存在了。秦国进军并消灭了他们。所以从军事角度来看，他们非常具有威胁性，但如果你是一个儒家，从意识形态角度来看，他们也非常。
And Jie Yi is a bird lover. So he writes a treatise on the owl. Right. The beauties of the owl, which I think is great. Love an owl. Yeah. But he's also a Confucian. And the hostility that he's displaying to the emperor there, he's drawing on kind of Confucian ideals and finding the first emperor wanting.
具有威胁性，因为他们有一个故意与孔子的假设相矛盾的统治前景，以及这种仁慈和仅仅执行正确的仪式等等就足以产生和谐的想法。这基本上是一种关于国家应该如何组织的极权主义理解。它在公元前四世纪，也就是未来始皇帝出生前的一个世纪，由一个叫商鞅的人传播。他明确谴责儒家美德是寄生的。所以他谴责的东西是礼乐、诗书、道德文化和美德、孝顺和兄弟之爱、真诚和信仰、仁义、对军队的批评。
Although I think, I mean, I think there is a measure of kind of grudging respect there as well, don't you think? Yeah. I mean, it stresses his omnipotence effectively, doesn't it? Yeah. But I think it's the earliest articulation of what will become a kind of prime Confucian theme running throughout Chinese history, that the first emperor had established his supremacy by consciously trampling on Confucian ideals. And because the history tends to be written by Confucians, it's quite difficult, I think, to have a sense of the first emperor
以及以战斗为耻。所有这些都被谴责为弱点。所以非常斯巴达。是的，确实。实际上，汤姆，这让我想起，你在年初做的那期精彩的节目，关于纳粹主义意识形态和纳粹对权利的感知的令人不寒而栗的节目。
himself that isn't clouded by that criticism. So it's again, looking at the kind of Roman parallel. It's like senators writing about the early Caesars. The hostility is baked in. Right. So that's our sense of this guy. Now, interestingly, throughout this podcast, we've called him this bloke or the first emperor, but we haven't really used his name very much. And that's partly because his name changes doesn't it over time it does so you compared him to augustus yeah and augustus was a great one for changing his name and the first emperor is is very similar his birth name seems to have been the jong which dominic as you'll know of course means kind of upright or proper correct yeah righteous or
他自己并没有被那种批评所蒙蔽。所以这又回到了罗马的类比。就像参议员们撰写关于早期凯撒的文章一样，敌意是根深蒂固的。没错。所以这就是我们对这个人的印象。有趣的是，在整个播客中，我们一直称他为这家伙或第一位皇帝，但我们并没有真正多用他的名字。这部分是因为他的名字随着时间而改变，不是吗？确实如此，所以你把他和奥古斯都相比，是的，奥古斯都非常喜欢改名，而第一位皇帝也非常相似。他的出生名字似乎是政，多米尼克，正如你所知，这当然意味着正直、恰当、正确，是的，正义或
implications of rectitude there tom for people who are real linguistic scholars i think yes exactly so and he is the son of the king of chin and a concubine and within decades of his death you're starting to get hostile confucian traditions that says that his father had been a hostage, which I guess is entirely plausible when he was a young man, and that while he was a hostage, he had befriended a merchant. And Confucians regard merchants with the utmost contempt. So this is a terrible thing. They're in trade. Common. They're in trade. And this merchant had given one of his concubines to the future king of Qin,
汤姆，对于那些真正的语言学者来说，这其中隐含着正直的意味，我想是的，完全正确。他是秦王和一个妃子的儿子。在他死后的几十年里，开始出现敌视他的儒家传统，声称他的父亲曾是人质，我想这在他年轻时是完全合理的。而且在做人质期间，他曾与一名商人结为好友。儒家对商人极其蔑视。所以这是一件可怕的事情。他们从事贸易。粗俗。他们从事贸易。而这名商人把他的一个妃子送给了未来的秦王，
and this concubine will be his mother. Although there are much later, again, very hostile Confucian traditions that go a step further and say that actually the king of Qin was the son of this merchant and his concubine and therefore was entirely legitimate. So you can see there a kind of deliberate attempt to try and blacken him. So he becomes king of Chin in 246 BC. He's only 13, so still very young. And he is heir to this very, very kind of formidable state. We compared it earlier to Rome or to the Macedon of Philip II and Alexander that conquers the Greek states. They have a very, very militaristic cast of mind, almost kind of Spartan level of toughness, very advanced technologically. So they've developed particularly lethal brand of crossbow. They have these huge, well-trained armies. Anyone who has seen Hero will remember the
而这个妃子后来成了他的母亲。尽管后来还有更具敌意的儒家传统更进一步，声称秦王实际上是这个商人和他妃子的儿子，因此完全不合法。所以你可以看到这是一种蓄意的抹黑尝试。他在公元前246年成为秦王。他当时只有13岁，还非常年轻。他是这个非常强大国家的继承人。我们之前把它比作罗马，或者腓力二世和亚历山大征服希腊城邦的马其顿。他们有一种非常尚武的思想，几乎达到了斯巴达式的坚韧程度，技术也非常先进。他们开发了一种特别致命的弩。他们拥有庞大且训练有素的军队。看过电影《英雄》的人都会记得
incredible scene where the earth shakes as the army of the Qin approaches. And so already only four years after Zhong has been born in 255, the Qin have embarked on their process of conquest. And specifically, they have targeted what remains of the patrimony of the Zhu dynasty. So this very, very ancient, highly respected dynasty that had existed for centuries and centuries before. And the Qin have marched in and have extinguished them. So they're very menacing from a kind of military point of view, but they are also very
那令人难以置信的场景，当秦军逼近时大地都在震动。早在政出生四年后的公元前255年，秦国就已经开始了他们的征服进程。具体来说，他们的目标是周朝残存的遗产。这个非常古老、备受尊崇的王朝已经存在了数百年。秦军长驱直入，将其灭亡。所以从军事角度来看，他们非常具有威胁性，但如果你是儒家学者，从意识形态的角度来看，他们也同样
menacing if you are a Confucian from an ideological point of view, because they have a prospectus for rule that deliberately contradicts the assumptions of Confucius and this idea that beneficence and just performing the correct rituals and so on will be enough to generate harmony. And it's basically a totalitarian understanding of how states should be organized. And it's been propagated in the fourth century, so the century before the future first emperor is born, by a guy called Shang, Lord Shang. And he explicitly condemns Confucian virtues as being parasitical. So the things that he condemns are rights and music, odes and history, moral culture and virtue, filial piety and brotherly love, sincerity and faith, benevolence and righteousness, criticism of the army,
具有威胁性，因为他们有一套统治纲领，故意与孔子的假设相矛盾，即仁慈和正确执行礼仪等就足以产生和谐。这基本上是一种关于国家应如何组织的极权主义理解。它是在公元前四世纪，也就是未来第一位皇帝出生前的一个世纪，由一个叫商鞅的人所传播的。他明确谴责儒家美德是寄生虫。他谴责的东西包括礼乐、诗书、道德修养和美德、孝悌、诚实和信仰、仁义，以及对军队的批评，
and being ashamed of fighting. All of these are condemned as weaknesses. So very Spartan. Yeah, it is. Very Spartan. And actually, Tom, it reminds me, you did that wonderful episode at the beginning of the year, chilling episode about the ideology of Nazism and the Nazis' sense of right and
以及以战斗为耻。所有这些都被谴责为弱点。所以非常斯巴达。是的，确实如此。非常斯巴达。事实上，汤姆，这让我想起你在年初做的那期精彩的节目，关于纳粹意识形态和纳粹对正义感的令人不寒而栗的节目
wrong. And, you know, the contempt for being ashamed of fighting, for being weak, for being soft, all of that kind of stuff. I mean, there are some pretty chilling 20th century parallels there. Yes. And of course, the Nazis were inspired by the Spartans. And I think that people may recognize the extent to which there are parallels between the current Chinese state and this kind of ideal that is being spelt out by Lord Shang in the 4th century BC. So essentially, the tendrils
错的。而且，你知道，那种对怯懦、软弱、柔弱的蔑视，所有这些东西。我的意思是，20世纪有一些相当令人不寒而栗的相似之处。是的。当然，纳粹也曾受到斯巴达人的启发。我认为人们可能会意识到，当前的中国国家与商鞅在公元前4世纪所阐述的这种理想之间存在着某种程度的相似性。所以本质上，国家的触角
of the state, Shang thinks, should reach into every household. So every household has to be registered, which in turn makes it easy to get taxes from them, to oblige people to do military service, to do forced labor. And you have these kind of pyramidal structure of magistrates who are responsible for communities and then higher magistrates and so on, right the way up to the figure of the king himself. This structure, Shang says, is to be enforced with very, very brutal laws. Essentially, he says, a king who is not brutal in maintaining the law is letting his people down. A king who is kind is letting the state go to waste. And this feeds into, on the military level, a sense that, say, head harvesting is the measure of a man.
商鞅认为，应该伸向每一个家庭。因此，每个家庭都必须登记在册，这反过来又使征税、强迫人们服兵役、服劳役变得容易。你拥有这种金字塔式的官僚结构，他们负责各个社区，然后是更高级的官员，以此类推，一直到国王本人。商鞅说，这种结构必须通过非常、非常残酷的法律来执行。本质上，他说，一个在维护法律方面不残酷的国王是在辜负他的人民。一个仁慈的国王是在让国家走向衰败。而在军事层面上，这助长了一种观念，即“斩首”是衡量一个男人价值的标准。
The more heads that a soldier can collect, the higher he will be promoted. And this is obviously anathema to everything that Confucian philosophy embodies. But it's obviously brilliant for the young Zhang, who, even though he's a teenager, shows himself brilliant at utilising both the war machine and this kind of ideology that he's a teenager, shows himself brilliant at utilizing both the war machine and this kind of ideology that he's been bequeathed. And so the wars carry on and the six kingdoms are swallowed up one by one. And as this process is happening, obviously all the other kings are terrified. The stories that are told of the king of chin is that he's a kind of almost bestial figure so there's a description of him that is
士兵收集的头颅越多，他得到的晋升就越高。这显然与儒家哲学所体现的一切背道而驰。但这对于年轻的秦王来说显然是天才之举，尽管他还是个少年，但他展现出了利用战争机器和这种被遗赠给他的意识形态的非凡才能。于是战争继续，六国被一个接一个地吞并。随着这一过程的发生，显然所有其他的国王都感到恐惧。关于秦王的传说，说他是一个近乎野兽般的人物，所以有一段对他的描述是
quoted by a later historian coming from one of his own generals that he's a man with a prominent nose large eyes a chest like a bird of prey and the voice of a jackal a man of little kindness with the heart of a tiger of that of a wolf terrifying so not the kind of person that you'd want coming for you yeah and so unsurprisingly they sponsor assassins to go and kill him and this is the historical reality that lies behind the plot of of hero oh yes but it doesn't work they all fail yes and so by 221 bc all the other six kingdoms have been conquered and And the estimate is, and again, it's quite a round figure. People may remember, I've mentioned before, that Caesar is said to have killed a million Gauls when conquering Gaul.
由后来的历史学家引用，来自他自己的一位将军，说他是一个长着突出的鼻子、大眼睛、胸部像猛禽、声音像豺狼的人，一个缺乏仁慈、有着老虎和狼一样心脏的人，非常可怕，所以不是那种你希望他来找你的人。是的，所以不出所料，他们资助刺客去杀他，这就是电影《英雄》情节背后的历史现实。哦，是的，但它没有成功，他们都失败了。是的，所以到了公元前221年，其他六国都被征服了。据估计，这又是一个相当整数的数字。人们可能还记得，我之前提到过，凯撒在征服高卢时据说杀了一百万高卢人。
Yeah. The same is said of the King of Chin, that he slaughters a million and more people in the process of conquering. That's a classical history million, isn't it, Tom? Yes. I mean, who's counting, right? Right. But so he is now,
是的。关于秦王也有同样的说法，说他在征服过程中屠杀了百万人以上。那是古典历史中的“一百万”，不是吗，汤姆？是的。我的意思是，谁在数呢，对吧？没错。但所以他现在，
so he's conquered all the kingdoms. Yes. And he makes himself more than a king. So that's why we call him the first emperor. He's different from the Zhu dynasty or previous dynasties because he is something else. He's a paramount ruler, par excellence. He is an emperor.
所以他征服了所有的王国。是的。他使自己不仅仅是一位国王。这就是为什么我们称他为“始皇帝”。他与周朝或之前的朝代不同，因为他是某种别的东西。他是卓越的最高统治者。他是皇帝。
Is that right? Yes. Well, so members of our beloved chat community will know that the Chinese for king, of course, is Wang. General Gordon, of course, had his Wangs, didn't he had his wangs his kings yeah but yeah so the king of chin no longer wants to be a king he no longer wants to be a wang and so he declares himself to be chin xi huangdi and chin is obviously his homeland chin is the name from which china
是这样吗？是的。嗯，我们敬爱的聊天社区成员会知道，中文里的“国王”当然是“王”。戈登将军当然有他的“王”，不是吗？他有他的“王”，他的国王。是的，但秦王不再想当国王了，他不再想当一个“王”，于是他宣布自己为“秦始皇帝”。“秦”显然是他的家乡，“秦”这个名字就是“中国”的来源。
will come yeah so his homeland comes to be acquainted with the entire empire that he's conquered she means first and this i find fascinating do you i mean this is why i find this subject so interesting coming from the kind of the roman perspective gone so huang basically means august oh very good. And Di is a divine figure. So the yellow emperor was a Di. The yellow emperor called himself Huang Di. And so if you wanted to translate Huang Di into Latin, you translate it as Augustus Divus, both of which were names used by Augustus because he wanted a new title for himself. The divine Augustus. So that I think is why the translation for Huangdi into
是的，所以他的家乡被等同于他征服的整个帝国。“始”意味着第一。我觉得这很迷人。你觉得吗？我的意思是，这就是为什么我发现这个主题如此有趣，从罗马的角度来看。好了，所以“皇”基本上意味着“奥古斯都”。哦，非常好。“帝”是一个神圣的人物。所以黄帝是一个“帝”。黄帝称自己为“皇帝”。所以如果你想把“皇帝”翻译成拉丁语，你会把它翻译成“Augustus Divus”，这两个名字都是奥古斯都使用的，因为他想要一个新的头衔。神圣的奥古斯都。所以我认为这就是为什么把“皇帝”翻译成
English appropriately is emperor. It's a kind of an implicit comparison between Augustus and Huangdi. And what makes it different, I suppose, is that in his name, there's that link to the gods, to the realm of the divine, right? Because of the D. So he's more than just an earthly monarch. He is the incarnation of cosmic order. Is that fair? I think absolutely, yes. And we have inscriptions that he put up himself, inscriptions incised onto great stone monuments. And so in that sense, a sense of himself has survived the criticism and the obloquy of later historians. And he describes himself as ruling over a land in which all men under the sky toil with a single purpose. And he describes himself as ruling over a land in which all men under the sky toil
英语是“Emperor”的原因。这是一种奥古斯都和皇帝之间隐含的比较。我想，使它与众不同的是，在他的名字里，有那种与神、与神圣领域的联系，对吧？因为有“帝”字。所以他不仅仅是一个世俗的君主。他是宇宙秩序的化身。这样说公平吗？我认为绝对公平，是的。我们有他亲自竖立的铭文，刻在巨大的石碑上的铭文。从这个意义上说，他对自己的一种认知在后世历史学家的批评和诋毁中幸存了下来。他描述自己统治着一片土地，在这片土地上，天下所有的人都为了一个共同的目标而劳作。他描述自己统治着一片土地，在这片土地上，天下所有的人都为了一个共同的目标而劳作。
with a single purpose. And he is praised for having regulated local customs, made waterways and divided up the land, cared for the common people, working day and night without rest, defining the laws, leaving nothing in doubt, making known what is forbidden. So he's casting himself as a kind of godlike figure whose supervision is for the good of everyone beneath his rule and tom you've compared him with roman emperors but is there also a comparison just thinking about the stone monument with the inscription saying he did this he did that the other all men worked under his rule you know waterways blah blah blah what strikes me is pharaohs is there a comparison to be made with pharaohs, and I think obviously we are living as we do in the West and much more familiar
他因规范了当地习俗、开凿水道、划分土地、关心平民、日夜不停地工作、制定法律、不留疑点、公布禁令而受到赞扬。所以他把自己塑造成一个神一样的人物，他的监督是为了他统治下每个人的利益。汤姆，你把他和罗马皇帝进行了比较，但考虑到那块刻有铭文的石碑，说他做了这个、那个、其他事情，所有人在他的统治下工作，你知道，水道等等，让我印象深刻的是法老，是否可以与法老进行比较？我认为显然我们生活在西方，对近东或地中海古代文明的伟大国王和皇帝更为熟悉。但我认为，在某种意义上，秦始皇是这些人物的等同物。但当然，他也是非常、非常独特的中国人。我认为他体现了一种极权主义，甚至超过了
with the great kings and emperors of the ancient civilizations of the Near East or the Mediterranean. But I think that there is a sense in which Ji Wangdi, the first emperor, is the equivalent of those figures. But of course, he is also very, very distinctively Chinese. And I think that he embodies a totalitarianism beyond even that that was dreamed of also very, very distinctively Chinese. And I think that he embodies a totalitarianism beyond even that that was dreamed of, say, by Akhenaten, who is the kind of classic totalitarian figure in Egyptian history. Because unlike Akhenaten, who essentially has to kind of invent a justification for totalitarianism, the first emperor already has it in the form of
阿肯那顿所梦想的那种极权主义，阿肯那顿是埃及历史上典型的极权主义人物。因为与阿肯那顿不同，阿肯那顿本质上必须为极权主义发明一种辩护，而始皇帝已经以这种形式拥有了它。
this ideology that's been divided by lord shang and essentially what he does once he's conquered these six kingdoms is he extends that totalitarian control across everything that he's conquered so the identity of the kingdoms gets kind of dissolved by the division of the first emperor's conquests into 36 provinces and within those again you get all these kind of subdivisions and subdivisions and subdivisions. So again, you have this sense that his agents are everywhere, keeping watch, controlling people. This is what enables him to raise armies and to impose forced labor and so on. And also he does something that may remind people of what the
这种由商鞅划分的意识形态，本质上，他在征服这六国后所做的是，将这种极权控制扩展到他征服的一切事物上。因此，王国的身份通过将始皇帝的征服地划分为36个郡而消解了，在这些郡内，你又得到了所有这些细分、细分和再细分。所以，你又有了这种感觉，他的代理人无处不在，监视着，控制着人们。这使他能够征集军队、强迫劳役等等。而且他还做了一些可能让人们想起
Assyrians or the Babylonians did when they abducted the Israelites or the people of Judah to their capitals after conquering them. The first emperor does something very similar. He orders 120,000 of the wealthiest families from across all the various kingdoms that he's conquered to come to his capital near present-day Tian and to bring all their weapons with them. So that was mentioned in the passage that you read and these weapons are melted down and they're converted into bells and into 12 bronze giant statues that are kind of erected as markers of his triumph and his process so symbols of his power yeah and his triumph over these other rival families and so the passage that you read as criticism and the passage that you know the ins and the passage that, you know,
亚述人或巴比伦人在征服以色列人或犹大人民后将他们劫持到首都时所做的事情。始皇帝做了非常相似的事情。他下令从他征服的所有各个王国中，将12万最富有的家庭带到他靠近今天咸阳的首都，并带上他们所有的武器。所以你读的那段话中提到了这一点，这些武器被熔化，被改造成钟和12尊巨大的青铜雕像，作为他胜利和过程的标志竖立起来，所以是他权力的象征，是的，以及他战胜这些其他敌对家族的象征。所以你读的那段话是批评，而你知道，
the inscriptions that the first emperor himself puts up as a marker of praise is this idea that he standardizes everything. So he standardizes coinage. He standardizes weights and measurements, imposes it across what will become China. He standardizes the size of chariot axles. Yeah.
始皇帝自己竖立的铭文作为赞美的标志，是这种他将一切标准化的想法。所以他统一了货币。他统一了度量衡，并将其强加于未来将成为中国的地方。他统一了战车车轴的尺寸。是的。
Well, you need to do that for roads if you're on a road system, right? You do need it for roads. And so again, like the Romans, the first emperor is a great, great road builder. Yeah. Or the Persians. Yeah, or the Persians. But he has access to all this forced labor.
嗯，如果你在道路系统上，你需要这样做，对吧？你确实需要它来修路。所以，再次像罗马人一样，始皇帝是一位伟大的筑路者。是的。或者波斯人。是的，或者波斯人。但他拥有所有这些强迫劳役。
You know, he can get kind of contingents of people to labor on the roads, kind of, you know, preparing the rubble, patting it down, lining it with ditches and trees and everything. And in the middle of these great highways, there is a kind of separate lane, which is only for the first emperor himself. And there's a story told of a nobleman who accidentally strays into it, who immediately gets executed. So very stern traffic laws. And it's very clear, I think, when he travels, who is the first emperor, because he's dressed all in black. This is his signature colour. When you have this great kind of, you know, he's going down the central lane of these highways.
你知道，他可以征调各种人来修路，你知道，准备碎石，压实它，用沟渠和树木等衬砌它。在这些宏伟公路的中间，有一条单独的车道，只供始皇帝本人使用。有一个关于一位贵族不小心误入其中而被立即处决的故事。所以交通法规非常严厉。而且我认为，当他旅行时，谁是始皇帝非常清楚，因为他全身穿黑。这是他的标志性颜色。当你拥有这种宏伟的，你知道，他沿着这些公路的中央车道行驶。
He's got these huge wide black chariots with their perfectly matching wheel gauges, black banners, fluttering flags, officials, great tall conical hats, black robes. I mean, unbelievably impressive and overwhelming. And the sense that, you know, a new age has dawned in which everything is joined and supervised and everything has its place. So on the face of it, Tom, you could argue that this is precisely the kind of balance and order that a few centuries earlier, Confucius and then his acolytes, his successors, had called for. So why did they end up hating this first emperor? Because they see it as being upheld by, one of the Confucian scholars says, its mutilations and punishments. Right. So rather than everyone knowing their place, the labourer being happy to labour,
他有这些巨大的黑色战车，有着完美匹配的轮距，黑色的旗帜，飘扬的旗帜，官员们，高高的圆锥形帽子，黑色的长袍。我的意思是，令人难以置信的印象深刻和压倒性。那种感觉，你知道，一个新时代已经到来，一切都被连接和监督，一切都有其位置。所以从表面上看，汤姆，你可以说这正是几个世纪前孔子及其门徒、继任者所呼吁的那种平衡和秩序。那么他们为什么最终会憎恨这位始皇帝呢？因为他们认为这是由——正如一位儒家学者所说——“刑罚”所支撑的。没错。所以，与其说每个人都知道自己的位置，劳工乐于劳作，
you know, the householder being happy to hold the house, whatever, it's dependent on forced labour, on conscription, on people being criminalised if they object to this. And the punishments are incredibly brutal and they kind of rise from having your beard shaved off. Shocking. So this is the penalty for beating your wife. And then you might have your head shaved. Right. Then you might be tattooed, which is a kind of marker of criminality.
你知道，户主乐于持家，等等，它依赖于强迫劳役，依赖于征兵，依赖于人们如果反对这一点就会被定罪。而且惩罚极其残酷，它们从剃掉胡须开始。令人震惊。这是殴打妻子的惩罚。然后你可能会被剃光头。没错。然后你可能会被纹身，这是一种犯罪的标志。
Yeah. Then you might be castrated and then you might have limbs amputated. Okay. That's pretty strict. Yeah, it is strict. And it's expressive of this determination to control everything. The eye of the emperor is everywhere, and his reach extends into the humblest nook and cranny across all these lands that he's conquered. I think that that is why you did burn books, but that he didn't bury Confucian scholars alive. But the fact that they are told and believed is expressive of things that the Confucian scholars feel are terrible. Because obviously,
是的。然后你可能会被阉割，然后你可能会被截肢。好吧。那相当严格。是的，它很严格。它表达了控制一切的决心。皇帝的眼睛无处不在，他的触角延伸到他征服的所有这些土地上最卑微的角落。我认为这就是为什么你确实焚书，但他并没有活埋儒家学者。但这些被讲述和相信的事实，表达了儒家学者认为可怕的事情。因为显然，
their objections to what the first emperor is doing is couched in terms of appeals to the past. They're drawing on Confucius, but they're also drawing on the kind of ideals of what previous rulers had done. And so this is what the first emperor is objecting to. He doesn't want that. And so he's advised in 213 by his leading advisor who says, in order to prevent dissent through endless harking back to the supposed glories of the past, books containing such information must be destroyed. So again, a kind of very totalitarian instinct. I mean, this is George Orwell, isn't it? Yeah. No other sources of information, no other sources of wisdom, but me,
他们对始皇帝所作所为的反对，是以诉诸过去的形式表达出来的。他们借鉴孔子，但也借鉴了以前统治者所做的那种理想。所以这就是始皇帝所反对的。他不想要那个。所以他在公元前213年受到他首席顾问的建议，他说，为了防止通过不断回顾过去所谓的辉煌来产生异议，包含此类信息的书籍必须被销毁。所以，这又是一种非常极权的本能。我的意思是，这是乔治·奥威尔，不是吗？是的。没有其他信息来源，没有其他智慧来源，只有我，
effectively. Exactly. And the only manuals that are specified as being saved, they will save books of divination because the first emperor is obsessed by the occult and by looking into the future. Books on medicine and books on agriculture. And people who listened to our episode on Carthage may remember that we talked about how the Romans only allow agricultural manuals to be spared. Everything else is destroyed. And even though the scholars probably aren't buried alive, there's no question that Confucianism and Taoism, the first emperor is not in favour of them at all. So in the passage that you read, they talk about the hundred schools being banned.
有效地。完全正确。唯一被指定保存的手册是占卜书，因为始皇帝沉迷于神秘学和窥探未来。医学书籍和农业书籍。听过我们关于迦太基那一集的人可能还记得，我们谈到了罗马人只允许农业手册被保留。其他一切都被销毁。即使学者们可能没有被活埋，毫无疑问，儒家思想和道家思想，始皇帝根本不支持它们。所以你读的那段话中，他们谈到了“百家”被禁止。
These are all the sages who are essentially being told, you have no role to play in this new order. And against that background, one of regulation and control, building the great wall, which supposedly started in 214 BC, and the reading that we began the second half of the set is General Meng who does it. So the greatest general of the first emperor. So against that background, I mean, it's a bit like Hadrian's Wall, isn't it? Is it keeping the barbarians out or is it more simply just a demonstration of power and regulation and your ability to shape the landscape and to place a marker
这些都是圣人，本质上被告知，在这个新秩序中你们没有角色可扮演。在这种监管和控制的背景下，修建长城，据说是从公元前214年开始的，我们下半部分开始阅读的内容是蒙恬将军所做的。所以是始皇帝最伟大的将军。所以在这个背景下，我的意思是，这有点像哈德良长城，不是吗？它是为了把野蛮人挡在外面，还是仅仅是一种权力和监管的展示，以及你塑造景观和放置标记的能力？
on the earth and say, here I am, I can do whatever I like, I control this world. Well, that's why Borges is fascinated by it, isn't it? It's this sense that it's expressive of a will, of a purpose that is more than merely geopolitical. Yeah. I mean, I think clearly it is the idea of keeping barbarians out who are much more dangerous to the Chinese emperor than the Caledonians were to the Romans. Right. So it has a much more serious defensive purpose than Hadrian's Wall did. I think so. But I think it is also expressive of an ambition to regulate and control everything. And that which cannot be regulated, therefore,
在地球上说，我在这里，我可以做任何我想做的事，我控制这个世界。嗯，这就是博尔赫斯对它着迷的原因，不是吗？这是一种感觉，它表达了一种意志，一种不仅仅是地缘政治的目的。是的。我的意思是，我认为显然它是为了把野蛮人挡在外面，他们对中国皇帝来说比喀里多尼亚人对罗马人更危险。没错。所以它比哈德良长城有更严肃的防御目的。我想是的。但我认为它也表达了一种监管和控制一切的野心。因此，那些无法被监管的东西，
shouldn't be tolerated and is to be kept out. And so in that sense, again, a bit like Hadrian's Wall, the Great Wall is a marker of contempt for everything that lies beyond it. So the Great Wall is not what immediately comes into mind when you think about it, which is much later, the stretches beyond Beijing. Richard Nixon. This is a Great Wall. Yeah, Richard Nixon. It's a Great Wall. Yeah. Actually, these are not built out of stone probably they're made out of of earth so
不应该被容忍，应该被拒之门外。所以从这个意义上说，再次像哈德良长城一样，长城是对其之外一切事物的蔑视的标志。所以长城并不是你想到它时立刻想到的东西，那是更晚的，北京之外的延伸。理查德·尼克松。这是一道长城。是的，理查德·尼克松。这是一道长城。是的。实际上，这些可能不是用石头建造的，它们是用土做的，所以
there's a phrase for it the earth dragon you know kind of sneaking across the landscape for thousands of miles and probably not a coherent line so julia lovell in her brilliant book on the great wall of china she says that wall building was more a case of joining ravines and precipices with stretches of wall or with fortresses and of erecting a brand new continuous line of defence. But even so, it is clearly an absolutely massive project. And you get testimony to this. So there's a very haunting contemporary poem. If you have a son, don't raise him. If you have a girl, feed her dried meat. Can't you see the long wall is propped up on skeletons so very eerie so a little bit like the pyramids or something yeah slave labor huge armies for this grandiose hubristic statement of supreme power yeah and there's a very haunting story that
有一个短语，“土龙”，你知道，在数千英里的景观中蜿蜒穿行，可能不是一条连贯的线。所以朱莉娅·洛弗尔在她关于中国长城的精彩著作中说，修筑长城更多是将峡谷和悬崖与长城段或堡垒连接起来，而不是竖立一条全新的连续防御线。但即便如此，这显然是一个绝对巨大的工程。你得到了对此的证明。所以有一首非常令人难忘的当代诗。如果你有儿子，不要养他。如果你有女孩，喂她干肉。难道你没看到长城是靠骨架支撑的吗？所以非常阴森，有点像金字塔之类的。是的，奴隶劳工，巨大的军队，为了这个宏伟、傲慢的最高权力声明。是的，有一个非常令人难忘的故事，
kind of makes explicit this idea that actually the great wall has been made out of skeletons and the story is is that there is this woman she's got married. And on the very day of her marriage, the first emperor's agents come to seize him for his spell of duty doing forced labor on the Great Wall, right the way up on the kind of the northeastern side where the Great Wall meets with the ocean. And the poor man goes off and then winter comes and so the wife prepares him warm clothes she travels all the way up and when she gets there she discovers that her husband has already died of exhaustion and the bitter cold and she she sobs and she sobs and sobs and her tears dissolve the earth of the wall, and it all crumbles away and melts away.
某种程度上明确了这个想法，即实际上长城是由骨架制成的，故事是这样的，有一个女人，她结婚了。就在她结婚的那天，始皇帝的代理人来抓他去服强迫劳役，在长城上，一直到东北侧长城与海洋交汇的地方。那个可怜的男人走了，然后冬天来了，所以妻子为他准备了暖和的衣服，她一路赶去，当她到达那里时，她发现她的丈夫已经因精疲力竭和严寒而死，她哭啊哭啊哭，她的眼泪溶解了长城的土，它全部崩塌融化了。
And there are the bones of her husband, along with those of thousands of other people who have also died. These skeletons are kind of tumbling out, and she hurls herself into the sea. And her death, too, is expressive of the tyranny of the first emperor and i think that this desire to control everything is also what explains the stories that are told about his quest for immortality because if you can control everything in life you also want to keep death at bay yeah and so this is why he allows kind of necromantic manuals treatises written by magicians to be spared and not be burnt. And he goes to these magicians and he says, you know, how can I stay alive? I don't want to, I don't want to die.
那里有她丈夫的骨头，还有成千上万其他也死去的人的骨头。这些骨架像是在翻滚出来，她把自己投进了大海。她的死也表达了始皇帝的暴政，我认为这种控制一切的欲望也解释了关于他寻求长生不老的传说，因为如果你能在生活中控制一切，你也想把死亡拒之门外。是的，所以这就是为什么他允许某种招魂手册、魔术师写的论文被保留而不被焚烧。他去找这些魔术师，他说，你知道，我怎样才能活下去？我不想，我不想死。
Again, kind of echoes of Gilgamesh in Mesopotamian culture. And the magicians tell him that out in the ocean, there are three islands. And this is where people who are immortal live and we would love to go and look for them for you and to do that we will require thousands of young girls and boys to go with us right and um first emperor says brilliant off you go and so they they all set off and they never come back and so a few years pass and so some more magicians come and they say the same and so the first emperor rounds up more girls and boys and they all head off. And again, nothing happens. God, this is very dodgy behavior from the magicians, Tom, I think.
再次，美索不达米亚文化中吉尔伽美什的回响。魔术师告诉他，在海洋中，有三座岛屿。这就是长生不老的人居住的地方，我们很乐意去为你寻找他们，为了做到这一点，我们将需要成千上万的年轻女孩和男孩和我们一起去。没错，嗯，始皇帝说，太棒了，你们去吧。于是他们都出发了，再也没有回来。所以几年过去了，又来了一些魔术师，他们说了同样的话，所以始皇帝又召集了更多的女孩和男孩，他们都出发了。结果，什么也没发生。天哪，这对魔术师来说是非常狡猾的行为，汤姆，我想。
And then finally, one survivor comes back, one of the boys. Right. And he says, you know, we just can't get there. It's impossible. The ocean is full of monsters and the islands are guarded by giant sea monsters. How we going to get there and you know this is a very awkward question for the first emperor to answer yeah it's a bad blow for his ambitions and his anxiety to answer it is sharpened for him by the fact that in 211 a meteor crashes down lands on the earth and someone writes on it the first emperor will die and his lands will be divided up a chilling prophecy and obviously the emperor is not pleased about this
最后，有一个幸存者回来了，其中一个男孩。没错。他说，你知道，我们根本到不了那里。这不可能。海洋里充满了怪物，岛屿由巨大的海怪守卫。我们怎么能到那里呢？你知道，这对始皇帝来说是一个非常尴尬的问题。是的，这对他的野心是一个沉重的打击，他回答这个问题的焦虑因为211年一颗流星坠落到地球上而加剧，有人在上面写着“始皇帝将死，他的土地将被瓜分”，这是一个令人不寒而栗的预言，显然皇帝对此并不高兴。
and so he has the stone crushed and everyone around wiped out but it incentivizes him to go in person in quest for the immortality and these islands and so he heads off to the coast with a massive great train in his wake. And because he's been told that there are sea monsters out there, he has batteries and batteries of crossbows. He arrives on the coast. The story is that he sees some of the sea monsters, successfully shoots them, but then he dies. And because they are so far from the capital and because his aides and his followers are so nervous about what will happen if the news gets out that he's dead, they put him inside a covered kind of chariot and veil it so that no one can see him. And they pretend that he's still alive and they kind of bring him papers and so on. And they then start heading back to the capital. but because obviously his body is starting to rot what they do is they pile great wagons full of fish
所以他让人把石头砸碎，把周围的人全部消灭，但这激励他亲自去寻找长生不老和这些岛屿。于是他带着一支庞大的队伍前往海岸。因为他被告知那里有海怪，他带了成排成排的弩。他到达了海岸。故事是说他看到了一些海怪，成功地射杀了它们，但随后他就死了。因为他们离首都太远，而且他的助手和追随者非常担心如果他死的消息传出去会发生什么，他们把他放进一种带盖的战车里，并遮住它，这样就没人能看到他。他们假装他还活着，他们带给他文件等等。然后他们开始返回首都。但因为显然他的尸体开始腐烂，他们所做的是堆积了装满鱼的大车
to go in front and behind so that no one can smell the rotting of the human corpse i like that story but tom it occurs to me that it probably isn't true no i mean so that story has the absolute i mean that clearly seems to be a kind of folk tale stroke parable about his hubris. Yeah. It's kind of Arabian Nights quality, isn't there? Arabian Nights quality, exactly. So that probably, I mean, I'm such a stuck record on this whenever we do ancient history, but that probably didn't happen. Am I right? I mean, I think that there are elements of what we've been talking about that are clearly true. There are contemporary inscriptions. There are intellectual trends that you can trace and map. So we know he lived, we know he was the first emperor, but the fish business. Completely. But I agree that there is around him the quality of
在前面和后面，这样就没人能闻到人类尸体腐烂的味道。我喜欢那个故事，但汤姆，我想到它可能不是真的。不，我的意思是，那个故事绝对有，我的意思是，这显然似乎是一种关于他傲慢的民间传说或寓言。是的。它有一种《一千零一夜》的特质，不是吗？《一千零一夜》的特质，完全正确。所以那可能，我的意思是，每当我们做古代历史时，我在这方面就像一张卡住的唱片，但那可能没有发生。我是对的吗？我的意思是，我认为我们一直在谈论的事情中，有些元素显然是真的。有当代的铭文。有一些你可以追踪和映射的知识趋势。所以我们知道他活过，我们知道他是始皇帝，但鱼的事情。完全是。但我同意他周围有一种
myth. And I think that that's what appealed to Paul Guest. I think that's why he's such a resonant figure still in contemporary Chinese culture. That he is a kind of intersection point where myth and history kind of meet and merge. And part of the reason for the mythic quality is that so much of what he laboured has survived, but also quite a lot of the stuff that would have enabled him to be portrayed as he would have wanted to be portrayed collapses. Because as we said, his regime goes within four years. He's succeeded by the second emperor, but then that's it. And so emperors throughout Chinese history, you don't have the 43rd emperor or whatever. That tradition fades with the first and second emperor. And so in that sense, the kind of the portrait that we have of him is not one that he would have wanted. And that's why throughout the span of. And they say, bad guy, tyrant, totalitarian. I mean, that guy, you quoted Jia He.
神话的特质。我认为这就是吸引博尔赫斯的原因。我认为这就是为什么他在当代中国文化中仍然是一个如此有共鸣的人物。他是一个神话和历史交汇融合的交叉点。神话特质的部分原因是，他所劳作的很多东西都幸存了下来，但很多本可以让他被描绘成他想要被描绘的样子东西也崩溃了。因为正如我们所说，他的政权在四年内就灭亡了。他由二世皇帝继位，但随后就结束了。所以中国历史上的皇帝，你没有第43位皇帝之类的。那个传统在第一和第二位皇帝之后就消失了。所以从这个意义上说，我们对他拥有的肖像并不是他想要的。这就是为什么在整个跨度中。他们说，坏人，暴君，极权主义者。我的意思是，那个人，你引用了贾谊。
His thing is called the Faults of Qin. And he says, you know, Qin became a great power, but the ruler lacked humaneness and rightness. Preserving power differs fundamentally from seizing power. Yeah. In other words, this is a warlord, a jumped up warlord, who didn't know how to rule in a benevolent way. Yes, exactly. And so that's a tradition that the communists obviously inherit. You know, the communists are not in favour of autocratic emperors.
他的文章叫《过秦论》。他说，你知道，秦成为了一个大国，但统治者缺乏仁义。保持权力与夺取权力有着根本的不同。是的。换句话说，这是一个军阀，一个暴发户军阀，不知道如何以仁慈的方式统治。是的，完全正确。所以这是一个共产党显然继承的传统。你知道，共产党不支持专制皇帝。
No. And so in the kind of early decades of the communist state, again, the first emperor is absolutely condemned, along with all the other emperors. But I think two things then change to present the first emperor in a kind of brighter light. And the first, of course, is the discovery of the terracotta army, which is just, you said about seeing those three statues in the British Museum when they came over. I mean, there are thousands and thousands of them. You have archers, crossbowmen, foot soldiers in armor, officers, people on horses, people riding chariots. Absolutely stupefying. And it has been suggested that they reflect a kind of very distant Hellenic influence. Because of course, this is the age of Alexander's conquests, Hellenistic kingdoms in the East, that craftsmen
不。所以在共产主义国家成立的早期几十年里，始皇帝再次与所有其他皇帝一起被绝对谴责。但我认为两件事随后发生了变化，以一种更明亮的光芒呈现始皇帝。第一，当然是兵马俑的发现，这只是，你提到了在大英博物馆看到那三尊雕像，当它们被运过来时。我的意思是，有成千上万个。你有弓箭手、弩手、穿盔甲的步兵、军官、骑马的人、坐战车的人。绝对令人震惊。有人建议它们反映了一种非常遥远的希腊影响。因为当然，这是亚历山大征服的时代，东方的希腊化王国，工匠
in this period possibly are available. But to quote Frances Wood, who wrote a brilliant book on the first emperor of China, she says that the assembly of the buried army was an industrial rather than an artistic project. And what she means by that is that it's all mass produced. So you have eight different types of head, but only two types of legs, of armor, of feet. But Frances Wood is brilliant on how, despite this, when you look at the ranks of the terracotta army, you have this sense of incredible variety. So she says there are only two types of hand forms found amongst the 16,000 hands of the terracotta warriors, yet their use, their precise placing in the long sleeves of gown or tunic and the angles used help create
在这个时期可能是有可能的。但引用弗朗西丝·伍德的话，她写了一本关于中国始皇帝的精彩著作，她说埋葬军队的组装是一个工业项目，而不是艺术项目。她的意思是它是全部大规模生产的。所以你有八种不同类型的头，但只有两种类型的腿、盔甲、脚。但弗朗西丝·伍德在这一点上很出色，尽管如此，当你看着兵马俑的行列时，你有一种令人难以置信的多样性的感觉。所以她说在16000个兵马俑的手中只发现了两种类型的手形，但它们的使用，它们在长袍或外衣长袖中的精确放置以及所使用的角度有助于创造
an illusion of individuality. I'm sure she's right. I mean, I can't think of another one. She says it is the most extraordinary example of creative mass production in the world. And the fact that the state can do that, the fact that the authorities have the power to order that is a sign of their muscle, isn't it? And of their bureaucracy and their administrative clout, I guess. He builds on an enormous scale. So the terracotta army is only a part of the huge tomb complex. Which hasn't fully been excavated, right? So the tomb itself has never been excavated. Well, so there's an account of it that it contains flowing rivers of mercury. There's an attempt to create an image of the world within the tomb. And they've kind of done geo scans and apparently there is a very high mercury level in it. So people are kind of
一种个性的错觉。我相信她是正确的。我的意思是，我想不出另一个。她说这是世界上最非凡的创造性大规模生产的例子。国家能够做到这一点，当局有权下令做到这一点，这是他们肌肉的标志，不是吗？以及他们的官僚机构和行政影响力，我想。他在巨大的规模上进行建设。所以兵马俑只是巨大陵墓群的一部分。还没有完全挖掘出来，对吧？所以陵墓本身从未被挖掘过。嗯，有一个关于它的记载，它包含流动的汞河。有人试图在陵墓内创造一个世界的形象。他们进行了地理扫描，显然里面有非常高的汞含量。所以人们有点
nervous of exploring it. Do you know why they haven't opened it up fully? I think that it's kind of polluted. I think it's felt to be dangerous to excavate because of all this mercury. And the story is that when his palace burns in the wake of his death, it takes five days to burn. His buildings are obviously on an enormous scale. So I think that the terracotta army give a face to what would otherwise be a figure without features, perhaps, you might say, because all the images of him are much later. But because it's like with Tutankhamen, the moment you see something brought from the earth, redeemed from obscurity, that is vivid and personal, it kind of brings that figure alive. Yes, it does.
害怕探索它。你知道为什么他们没有完全打开它吗？我认为它有点污染。我认为人们觉得挖掘它很危险，因为所有这些汞。故事是说，当他的宫殿在他死后被烧毁时，烧了五天。他的建筑显然规模巨大。所以我认为兵马俑给本来可能是一个没有特征的人物赋予了一张脸，也许你可以这么说，因为所有关于他的图像都是后来的。但因为这就像图坦卡蒙一样，当你看到从地球中带出来的东西，从默默无闻中拯救出来，那是生动和个人的，它让那个形象活了起来。是的，确实。
So I think that that's one aspect. But the other, amazingly, as we talked at the beginning of this episode, is that over the recent decades, the first emperor has come to be promoted by the Communist Party in China. And it all originates in a story that we talked about, Dominic, in an episode that we did with Rana Mitter on the final days of mao and then the emergence of modern china which is this figure lin bao he had a key role in the civil war kind of very committed communist yeah at one point mao's heir apparent and he is the guy who compiles the little red book so the collection of mao sayings that then everyone kind of waves and brandishes but by the early 70s mao is starting to feel that perhaps he's too much of an heir apparent. It's obviously a very dangerous role to play and starts thinking, well, I don't know, maybe I should get rid of him.
所以我认为这是一个方面。但另一个，令人惊讶的是，正如我们在本集开头所谈到的，在最近几十年里，始皇帝开始受到中国共产党的推崇。这一切都源于一个故事，多米尼克，我们在与拉纳·米特尔的一集中谈到过，关于毛泽东的最后日子，然后是现代中国的出现，这就是林彪这个人物，他在内战中扮演了关键角色，某种非常坚定的共产主义者，是的，一度是毛泽东的法定继承人，他是编写《毛主席语录》的人，也就是每个人后来挥舞的那本毛泽东语录集，但到了70年代初，毛泽东开始觉得他可能太像法定继承人了。这显然是一个非常危险的角色，并开始想，嗯，我不知道，也许我应该摆脱他。
And accusations start to float around that Lin Bao is preparing a coup. and whether he is or not he gets sufficiently alarmed by this that on the 13th of September 1971 he gets on a plane to try and get to the Soviet Union to escape Mao and it crashes in Mongolia and everything around the story is incredibly mysterious but anyway Lin Bao then has to be purged his memory has to be eliminated and one of the accusations that's levelled against him in the wake of his death by Mao's propagandists is that he had compared Mao to the first emperor. And so what Mao's propagandists do in the wake of this is to say, well, this is outrageous. The first emperor was brilliant. And the reason that the first emperor is framed as being brilliant is firstly, that he had built a state where there had been
指控开始流传，说林彪正在准备政变。无论他是否在准备，他对此感到足够惊慌，以至于在1971年9月13日，他登上了一架飞机，试图前往苏联逃离毛泽东，结果在蒙古坠毁，故事周围的一切都极其神秘，但无论如何，林彪随后必须被清洗，他的记忆必须被消除，毛泽东的宣传家在他死后对他提出的指控之一是，他曾将毛泽东与始皇帝进行比较。所以毛泽东的宣传家在随后的做法是说，嗯，这太离谱了。始皇帝是天才。而始皇帝被塑造成天才的原因首先是，他在曾经有
chaos which is what Mao had done so Mao is to be compared to the first emperor in that sense but also the claim is that Lin Bao had been a secret enthusiast for Confucius right and so there is this maxim criticize Lin Bao criticize Confus. And Mao himself says all reactionary classes venerate Confucianism and oppose the first emperor. And so therefore, by an amazing process, to criticize the first emperor comes to seem sinister and counter-revolutionary. I mean, it's such an extraordinary maneuver. I looked this up because you told me about it before we recorded. So there was a biography published a couple of years i think after the death of lin biao by a guy called hong shi di and it was published by the state you know state sanctioned effectively and it was marketed as a
混乱的地方建立了一个国家，这正是毛泽东所做的，所以毛泽东在那个意义上要与始皇帝进行比较，但也声称林彪曾是孔子的秘密爱好者，对吧？所以有一个格言，“批林批孔”。毛泽东本人说，所有反动阶级都尊崇儒家思想，反对始皇帝。因此，通过一个惊人的过程，批评始皇帝似乎变得险恶和反革命。我的意思是，这是一个如此非凡的策略。我查了一下，因为你在我们录音前告诉过我。所以有一本传记，我想是在林彪死后几年由一个叫洪世迪的人出版的，它是由国家出版的，你知道，实际上是国家批准的，它被营销为
popular history the life of the first emperor so that we're in the early mid 70s it sold almost two million copies within two years. Of course, because China's a big place and it's being pushed by the party. And in this book, the first emperor Qin Shi Huang, he's a farsighted ruler. He establishes China as a modern state. It doesn't mention all the stuff about looking for immortality in the fish, because that's obviously- Disappointing omission. It messes up the narrative, but it absolutely presents him as the founding father of China. And actually, the criticism is that he wasn't tough enough, that he wasn't harsh enough.
通俗历史，《秦始皇传》，所以我们在70年代初中期，它在两年内卖出了近两百万册。当然，因为中国是一个大地方，而且它是由党推动的。在这本书中，秦始皇是一位有远见的统治者。他将中国建立为一个现代国家。它没有提到所有关于寻找长生不老和鱼的事情，因为那显然是——令人失望的遗漏。它搞乱了叙事，但它绝对把他呈现为中国的开国元勋。实际上，批评是他不够强硬，不够严厉。
And there's a quotation supposedly attributed to Mao, who's supposed to have said this in 1969, even before Lin Biao died, but how much this is true, it's hard to say. He says of the first emperor, he buried 460 scholars alive, but we have buried 46,000 scholars alive. This is Mao talking. You revile us for being Qin Shi Huangs, but you're wrong. We have surpassed Qin Shi Huang a hundredfold. And when you berate us for imitating his despotism, we are happy to agree. Now, whether or not Mao really said that, I don't know, but it's an interesting sign of how much the late stage Maoist regime was keen to associate itself with that first emperor and the sort of sense of order.
有一个据说是毛泽东的引语，据说他在1969年，甚至在林彪死前就说过这话，但这有多少真实性很难说。他谈到始皇帝时说，他活埋了460个学者，但我们活埋了46000个学者。这是毛泽东在说话。你们辱骂我们是秦始皇，但你们错了。我们已经超过了秦始皇百倍。当你们责骂我们模仿他的专制时，我们很高兴同意。现在，毛泽东是否真的说了那句话，我不知道，但这是一个有趣的迹象，表明晚期毛泽东政权多么热衷于将自己与那位始皇帝以及那种秩序感联系起来。
And that reminds me, Tom, of Stalin and Ivan the Terrible. Stalin was really keen to associate himself with mythic figures from Russian history, you know, to place himself in that continuum. I mean, that's pretty much the position that the Chinese are in now, isn't it? I think so. The first emperor seen as somebody to admire. I mean, I was amazed when I watched Hero because, of course, you know, we come from a tradition where the idea of an absolute emperor establishing a, you know, a terrifying order isn't something to be celebrated. But in
这让我想起了斯大林和伊凡雷帝，汤姆。斯大林非常热衷于将自己与俄罗斯历史上的神话人物联系起来，你知道，将自己置于那个连续体中。我的意思是，这几乎就是中国人现在的处境，不是吗？我想是的。始皇帝被视为值得钦佩的人。我的意思是，当我观看《英雄》时，我很惊讶，因为当然，你知道，我们来自一个传统，即绝对皇帝建立一个，你知道，可怕秩序的想法并不是值得庆祝的事情。但在
Hero, it absolutely is celebrated. And the Chinese state wouldn't be allowing endless television series about him to be run unless they were saying, no, there are lessons to be learned here. Slightly disturbing, I have to say, Tom. I like a strong government, but maybe not that strong. But also, it is very expressive of how close ancient history is in China compared, say, to us when we look back to Rome. Yeah. Because there's a sense of unbroken continuity, isn't there? Maybe falsely, but there was an impression of that, which obviously we don't have with
《英雄》中，它绝对是值得庆祝的。如果中国政府不是在说，不，这里有经验教训可以吸取，他们就不会允许关于他的无休止的电视剧播出。有点令人不安，我必须说，汤姆。我喜欢强有力的政府，但也许没那么强。但也非常清楚地表达了古代历史在中国是多么接近，相比我们回顾罗马时。是的。因为有一种不间断连续性的感觉，不是吗？也许是虚假的，但有一种印象，这显然我们没有。
Rome. We don't regard ourselves. People sometimes try, perhaps slightly half-heartedlyedly to present themselves as the heir of Rome, but there's always been a sense of disjunction, partly because of Christianity, because of the fall of the Roman Empire and so on. But maybe in China, they don't really have that to the same degree. No. It's the same state, same place. And clearly the first emperor does play a massive role in that. And that's why I think
罗马。我们并不把自己视为罗马的继承者。人们有时会尝试，或许有些漫不经心地将自己表现为罗马的继承人，但总有一种脱节感，部分原因是基督教，部分原因是罗马帝国的衰落等等。但在中国，他们并没有那种程度的脱节。不，那是同一个国家，同一个地方。显然，秦始皇在其中扮演了极其重要的角色。这就是为什么我认为
he's worth having a look at. Yeah. What a strange and interesting story. That stuff And that's why I think he's worth having a look at. Yeah. What a strange and interesting story. That stuff about the fish. I think that's my favorite bit. Yeah. I mean, imagine how large the crossbow was to deal with a giant fish. Yeah. And who knows what happened to those blokes who went off with all the boys and girls. Yeah, I know. That's left untold. Yeah. what happened to those guys right so tom that was brilliant that was a real tour de force and later this week we have a complete change of tone don't we we do because we'll be back in a few days with the history of tailoring and of men's fashion of suits ties you name it we'll be talking about it. Great, great fun. And then after that, we will be traveling to the United States for the last stand of the Lakota, the life of General Custer and the story of the Ghost Dancers.
他值得我们去了解。是的。多么奇怪而有趣的故事。关于鱼的那部分，我想那是我最喜欢的部分。是的。我的意思是，想象一下那把弩得有多大才能对付一条巨鱼。是的。谁知道那些带着男孩女孩们离开的人后来怎么样了。是的，我知道。那部分没有交代。是的，那些人后来怎么样了。好的，汤姆，这太精彩了，真是一场杰作。本周晚些时候我们将彻底改变基调，不是吗？是的，因为几天后我们将回来讲述裁缝的历史，以及男士时尚、西装、领带等等，凡是你能想到的我们都会谈到。非常有趣。在那之后，我们将前往美国，讲述拉科塔人的最后一战、卡斯特将军的生平以及鬼舞者的故事。
So lots of exciting things to come. And on that bombshell, Tom, thank you very much. I should have foolishly, I should have looked up how to say goodbye in Mandarin. The master of tongues fails. But for once, I missed an opportunity to try and score a point. So I just have to say goodbye. Goodbye. That's a very positive note on which to end.
所以有很多令人兴奋的事情即将到来。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，非常感谢你。我本该愚蠢地查一下用普通话怎么说再见。语言大师失败了。但这一次，我错过了一个尝试得分的机会。所以我只能说再见。再见。这是一个非常积极的结束语。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》，这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。